hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today we're gonna be doing something a
little bit different yesterday I put up
a poll asking at your thoughts on the
newest event the honor games and to
leave a detailed comment as to why and
you may be put in a future video is it
the best event we've had is it trash did
you even play it let me know and over
3,000 people had answered that poll so
thank you guys so much and there's
probably a lot more people that are
answering by the time this video is up
but this video is gonna be split into
three different parts the first part is
gonna be going over the overview of what
the specific topic we're talking about
is the second part is gonna be the
community's thoughts and what everybody
thought in the comments and kind of
sharing everybody's thoughts so it's
gonna get the community involved and the
last part is gonna be my individual
thoughts I plan to do a lot of these in
the future so if you want to participate
subscribe to the channel and if you
already are definitely click the Bell
notification so you could be one of the
first answer so you have a better chance
of getting your comment read for the
video before we continue though I do
want to talk about today's sponsor
project Orochi and I've partnered up
with them numerous times in the past and
today is special since they're going to
be releasing new designs for the
clothing line this new collection
includes the sword st. in reference to
eachine from Socorro saitama from one
punch man and the EO set as well if
those don't tickle your fancy they also
have some older designs in the shop some
referencing for honor some referencing
secure Oh shadows die twice and others
that just look really cool if you want
to purchase some of these you could
check the link down in the description
to go to their website and you can use
the code on screen for a discount I
check out as I stay cute a project I
wrote you for continuing to sponsor the
channel but with that let's continue
with today's video the topic of today's
video is the honor games this event was
a pretty big surprise to a lot of us in
the community for the anniversary of the
game celebrating all the years we've had
with it this game with new cosmetics as
usual with music emotes while not
technically tied to the event because
they're still staying after the event is
gone
they were showcased and heavily talked
about within the event so those will
count for options of instruments that
when together actually sync up as well
as a new game mode which is like
carousel of death except with fire and
lots of fan art on the walls and so many
details hidden throughout the map like
the minions in the second week the
carousel fire was then changed to
carousel of Ragnarok were instead of
fire and sword buffs it was the one shot
hammer from the Jorma vent for the poll
answers though about the event at the
very very bottom we had
the terrible or bottom three / complete
worst event we've ever had at 3% below
average but not terrible at 4% amazing
which was top 3 or best event we've ever
had at 12 average at 20 and then good
but not amazing tier at a whopping 61%
from the pole so it's clear a lot of
people enjoyed the vent it wasn't
everybody's personal favorite like top 3
but it was still a nice event
nonetheless under the first comment is
from stripping who says the event is
good but then again it's not unique it's
fun and stuff but it will just go down
the drain like most event games
I'll give it a 7 out of 10 it's fun and
quick but should be permanent and added
to customs this actually brings up a
good point though lots of the community
has been wanting custom games to be
changed a lot by adding the past event
games it gives players the opportunity
to enjoy those game modes again whether
they're old players who want to play
them again and you know experience that
nostalgia or you're a new player and
I've never played these game modes
before they don't need to drop loot or
gain XP of course because there's just
custom games but it would just be nice
to play them regardless cuz after a
while the lobbies get toxic and boring
and queue times get really long so it's
nice to switch up and play with some
buddies on Ice brawlers and it would be
pretty good for youtubers and streamers
such as myself to get the community
involved imagine playing test your
mettle with your favorite youtubers
streamer I think that'd be fantastic
because test your mettle is easily one
of the best emotes ever added and I
think adding the event game modes is
something totally harmless and should
easily be a thing Isaac Clarke who took
time out of his busy schedule from
saving the world of Necromorphs has
stated that it's very nice but nothing
to write home about I think it's mostly
because I hated the Battle pass and they
left a sour taste in my mouth even if it
wasn't directly related to the event
itself I am interested though on how the
lore of the game is going to develop
after this truce that the factions have
and what new heroes will do about it I
couldn't agree more on the lore I
actually personally found the battle
pass pretty nice it gives me a reason to
play more but the lore in this game is
definitely changing and it seems to be
the center for the entire year and it
would be really intriguing to see what
the new heroes do whether they become
some of the evil harbingers we've had
from last year or some of more nicer
characters eager to uphold that truce
that they set I've been getting
questions a lot actually as to who those
characters are going to be what classes
what factions anything like that
and honestly of course I have no idea
but my hypothesis
that it most likely is going to be to
woolen heroes only because every single
faction has seven characters except the
woman who has five and adding two more
would make every faction even I have no
other proof other than that and that's
just my theory though regardless of the
faction it doesn't really matter to me
as long as the character isn't boring or
the customization is trash we also got
poor Jarvis here who sadly couldn't even
log into foreigner so if we can get an
effort Jarvis in the comments that'd be
much appreciated Pahlavi says it's okay
what I want to concentrate on is people
complaining about no weapons on this
event they seem to have forgotten that
we just got new weapons and armor it's
too early for the new ones either you
like the weapons or not they need time
to be worked on and probably someone
needed to review and approve them but I
bet in the next event we'll have weapons
too there's something I thought of as
well this is one of the few events I
think if not the only event where we
didn't get weapons this time I think he
put it well it's most likely due to the
fact that we just got weapons from the
new season and the fact that they put an
event pretty much in the first week of
the season at the very start was
crunching their time and trying to make
more stuff we had something similar like
this a couple years ago with a season
and event being within the first week I
think of a season 6 or season 7 I
believe but at that time there was no
armor so they had extra time to make
more weapons so let me know what you
guys would think do you guys want a
seasonal weapon set like season 9 weapon
season 10 weapons etc with an event
weapon that follows or would you rather
have a seasonal weapon set and an armor
set like we have during this season
disregarding the fact of course that the
weapons will most likely be in the
battle pass I'm thinking I'm cool with
getting no weapons for this event cuz
I've been craving armor for a very long
time lastly on the comments we have
Olivia so I've only been here since
marching fire but I liked it a lot to be
honest this mode is fun the Ragnarok
version is met but that's because it's
so easy to just one shot a lot of people
and it makes the games go by fast in my
opinion the events pretty good and the
whole celebration presentation of it was
good as well I like getting a wide range
of comments for this kind of thing
especially for a Livius case who's only
been here for about a year and missed
some of the past events and the very
beginning of the game and kind of
jumping in and it gives that different
approach as opposed to a veteran player
who's been here since day one or beta
everybody has kind of different opinions
depending on when they came in the game
and this is probably the biggest running
theme I've seen in the comments that
everyone agrees that the game mode was
really really fun until the
at the hammer and honestly I couldn't
agree more which I'll explain in my
analysis in the next part but I think to
end this part I think toxic put it very
very well
carousel afire was juicy carousel of
ragnarok was Dookie thanks to everyone
who sent in their comments there was so
many and I didn't want this video being
super super long so hopefully we'll try
to get to a lot more comments in the
next iteration of this video but for the
last part we will be going over my
thoughts and my thoughts in terms of the
poll I got to put myself in the amazing
category easily top 3 for me of polygons
legacy being number one this being
number two and the Raving Rabbids April
Fool's event if you want to count that
as an event which I do in third place
the event had some amazing qualities the
effects and outfits were nice even if
they weren't used as much the game mode
while not totally unique was still a
switch up from the regular carousel of
death which was my favourite from the
pure chaos of putting eight people in a
map design for to the atmosphere brought
was fantastic it actually felt like a
real place people were singing dancing
drinking playing music the leaders were
in the front on their chairs looking
onto the battlefield and the minions
guardians commanders and captains and
such all cheered when somebody died like
it was a mini Colosseum in terms of the
game-mode itself it was good but the map
was easily the best to remake I've ever
seen especially since I got the
community involved as the fenner on the
banners and being able to see your
emblems on the side was refreshing which
made it seem a bit more alive the NPC's
were actually doing lots of different
things as well as opposed to the knight
duel map in which daubeny would just sit
up on his chair and the others would
just watch and he would only speak every
now and then which was kind of an to me
and the trailer gave me flashbacks to
season 5 with the unique editing style
and announcer which was slightly
nostalgic the only parts of the event
that were bad were the lack of weapons
and the game-mode changed not having
weapons sucked as previously stated it's
understandable though as to why we
didn't get any Andy carousel of Ragnarok
while fun for a bit because of the
insane chaos that came with it quickly
became annoying and unfun the more I
played it other than that guys that's
going to be my thoughts on the video let
me know what you guys think about this
stuff in the comments below as always
like the video if you do enjoy as I
stated we're gonna be doing a lot more
of this stuff in the future with the
upcoming event if we get one this season
which I believe we were confirmed to
probably have two this season and then
of course the upcoming seasons
throughout the whole year there's gonna
be lots of more stuff
about with those with the new characters
the new battle passes the new weapons
potentially new armor and of course the
events and the lore that accompany it
see as always if you want to participate
with this stuff that definitely make
sure to subscribe to the channel and
then make sure you have the Bell
notification on so that you could be the
first to answer so you have a better
chance of getting your comment read for
the video as I was thinking to the
people that commented whether you were
featured in the video or not they do to
the people that of course have voted in
the poll and hopefully we could do a lot
more with this stuff next time because
this is actually a hell of a lot of fun
and I really enjoyed this video it was
always like to be if you doings like I
subscribe for a new I cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the here
updates the patch notes and the leaks if
you want to be kept up today with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner and every US out on an update
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
I guess take care have a great day and
peace out
[Music]
you